visite guidée de la mairie pour les
habitants après plus de huit mois de
travaux les morts patients ont découvert
le nouvel espace d'accueil de l'hôtel de
ville une présentation commentée par les
agents municipaux
les bureaux sont indépendants tout ça au
point de vue non je trouve ça très très
bien au point de vue éclairage et tous
et pour l'accueil bas je pense que ça
sera mieux que ça sera mieux qu'avant
mais c'est un bonheur pour tous les
usagers et puis tous ceux qui vont
travailler dans cette mairie depuis de
nombreuses années ils vont pouvoir avoir
le confort au quotidien guichet unique
réorganisation des services
modernisation du matériel informatique
pour un investissement global d'un
million d'euros nous développons de
nouveaux outils sûr
l'internet est aussi l'accueil physique
est très important au travers de de
plusieurs modes d'organisation l'accueil
et aussi l'organisation même sur le
plateau du rez de chaussée avec des
modes de
d'organisation repenser une
réorganisation visible avec une
modification dans la structure des
bureaux et la mutualisation des services
en trois pôles pôle citoyen paul famille
et pôle loisirs l'umq rénovation qui
permet d'apporter aux aux agents
meilleures conditions de travail et donc
avec ses meilleures conditions de
travail de mieux accueillir les usagers
l'ancien enfance éducation est devenu
pôle famille
il a regroupé du coup la vie scolaire la
l'enfance et la petite enfance pour la
cinquantaine d'agents municipaux de la
mairie de maurepas la transversalité
entre les pôles sera essentiel pour
servir efficacement les administrés